welcome to this video playing William
Wilson to William Walton the Sun some
character from a book or something don't
know probably not the real name got a
German just like a swan song ok we have
a Bishop b5 the solely in the Russell
emo he's very deliberately giving up his
light squared Bishop which yeah it's not
it's not terribly big concession but I'm
not concerned at all to have won the
bishop damn or let's say to not combat
the bishop pair anymore ok on Queen g3
I'm I'm intending to push our form so
make some some way pave the way for the
F 197 seemed like he wanted to play five
but now we know it doesn't hmm
interesting ok let's push it it's not
clear that this is so great
see form could be could be me this is
what i would consider c5 i take it um I
can even create a triple pawn ok go in
here ok maybe I can go f5 Bishop age 6
some split quickly to ship to ship to
have six mmm yeah I can go if I hear you
5 p-6 isn't this a good structure let's
do that high-five yeah i forgot about a
5 mm yeah that's not good I really
forgot about the smooth mmm yeah now is
sexism easily a liability
yeah that's not that's not good at all
hmm yeah they don't have a great pawn
structure with that for ya Black is in
very good shape p.m. he can even
consider 22 heck 1c3 and play night
Stewie 496 34 yeah but I would have
played be a b3 that's hmm that's
unexpected
ok
hmm
see going to you for I don't really
understand what's going on I can I can
also take it but this is probably not so
so great this Bishop is very strong then
hmm and there what I for singing okay I
need to move yeah money 6 i'm still I'm
still a bit annoyed with myself to have
overlooked a fine and this moment I
really liked the position but no I'm
okay
yeah I just gave away their full porn
yeah he 6 is just a terrible move it
gives away a good position to do to a
bad one before I'm just very comfortable
not nothing spectacular but just a good
position not quite sure what he is doing
what does the look doing on on an f2
where where is it going
maybe you can play Bishop t4i this looks
really strange but maybe you need to
move need to play that
yeah don't know yeah well I thought I
thought maybe night a form as weird as
it looks
Bishop takes Knight takes 94 f takes the
form and now I'm threatening to take
take on f2 web I don't know don't really
see what you should play I forgot about
that one oh my I need to break badly I'm
just overlooking all kinds of simple
moves wow wow wow whoo yeah one idea
three what's so difficult about that
check
yeah that's this look everyone even I
don't have any moves too young to tuyen
pose a slight problem checkmate yeah
yeah what an idiotic move e six bow I
mean why it is simply better here for
four absolutely for for nothing I mean
he just has a bad bishop on g7 let's say
they normal move just the normal move
and like is somewhat worse it's not it's
not the end of the world but I mean it's
it's a space advantage this Bishop is
bad on g7 just a very one-sided position
something like that you can try to
regroup like you hear hear but why has
the better structure also but I'm simply
giving the game away with this e 6 is a
double ? me with the after f5 his bishop
is strongest piece on the board and just
terrible very very bad I am I don't
again also not prevent c4 I mean this is
just a disaster no no way to to keep
this position playable if I would be
able to make two moves in a row like b3
Bishop g2 whoops then it's fine but I
cannot prevent see form and then all the
floodgates are opened and yeah even even
night 2d to this kind of strange move is
good now this is just just all good for
black yeah ships III even
it doesn't really doesn't really matter
yeah I just gave a game away with one
movie success we like is just playing
this a bit too lackluster giving giving
white all kinds of advantages but this
is just terrible and he punished me very
very nicely for that thanks for watching